it's safe to say that Deadpool 2 has
comfortably avoided sequel itis with
many standout moments even surpassing
the first nevertheless this hugely
entertaining family film with the twist
is not without a few small flaws so
buckle up and check the weather forecast
because we're jumping into gale force
winds to present the five best and the
five worst things in Deadpool to
spoilers ahead best a perfect x-force
first appearing in comic book form in
1991's New Mutants number 100 X forces
feature film arrival has been eagerly
anticipated since cable was first teased
in Deadpool's post-credit see oh but I
can't tell you one thing and it's a bit
of a secret the sequel we're gonna have
cable fortunately their arrival doesn't
disappoint with cable Domino and Russell
fitting into the team effortlessly by
the final act when Deadpool's outfit is
charred in a nod to his gray suited
x-force appearance it's clear Wade has
found his f-word worst no longshot
action Deadpool twos action definitely
isn't bad but fans of director David
leeches previous projects particularly
his work on John wick may feel
short-changed the reason could lie with
leeches filming style both Keanu Reeves
as John wick and Charlize Theron and
atomic blonde performed the majority of
their own stunts but that wasn't an
option for much of Deadpool to leech
told The Hollywood Reporter you need
those actors to want to do it otherwise
you won't get those genuine characters
on the screen
Reynolds however fractured vertebrae in
his neck on the set of 2012's safe house
and understandably hasn't performed his
own stunt sense best dominos luck as the
sole survivor among the new recruits
during the X forces inaugural mission
Domino clearly has what it takes
in the comics Domino superpower is
subconscious telekinesis that kicks in
when she's in high-stress situations
this forcefield manipulates her
surroundings and is responsible for
jamming the chambers of guns or
manipulating mirrors to blind her
enemies at just the right moment the
first time we really see her use those
powers is a beautiful moment in Deadpool
2 cars somersault and explosions erupt
around her as she nonchalantly escapes
arm-like final destination in Reverse
she defies odds in breathtaking fashion
worst and underutilized supporting cast
most of the first movie side characters
returned for Deadpool - and they were
joined by a ton of newcomers the scope
is larger yet Deadpool - runs just 11
minutes longer than its 2016 predecessor
with so many characters vying for screen
time something had to get Morena
Baccarin vanessa is the most obvious
oversight her romance with Wade was
intrical - Deadpool in the sequel
Vanessa is shot right at the beginning
making her little more than Wade's
off-screen motivation reactions to test
screenings saw her role is wasted and
it's hard to disagree after watching the
final cut
best hilarious cameos Deadpool's meta
humour is primed for scene stealing
cameos in the first movie stanley
appeared as a strip club DJ and deadpool
wore a printout of hugh jackman's face
as a mask in case the other Deadpool -
raised the bar with a host of hilarious
appearances from familiar faces old
footage of Jackman appears in a callback
to x-men origins Wolverine but that's
nothing compared to the rest
Deadpool's low-budget relative to the
rest of the x-men movies has been a
running self-aware joke wait out here ok
it's a big house it's funny that I only
ever see two of you it's almost like the
studio couldn't afford another x-man in
Deadpool 2 Wade finds himself back at
the x-mansion after being saved by
colossus as he again rants about the
lack of x-men Professor Xavier
Quicksilver Nightcrawler storm Cyclops
and beast appear in a room behind him a
Hollywood a-lister makes an appearance -
after colliding with a power cable
during the botched x-force mission
vanishes invisibility cuts out and the
audience can briefly see his real face
which looks a lot like Brad Pitt's last
but not least heavily disguised cameos
from alan tudyk and matt damon who
appeared briefly as a pair of friends
who get future tased and have their
truck stolen by cable after he arrives
from the future that's an awful lot of
hidden star power worst x-force xed out
while domino Russell and cable were
amazing additions to Deadpool - what
about the team members who were
introduced only to be brutally executed
on their first mission as a team bedlam
zeitgeist shatter star Vanisher Domino
and Peter skydive in the high winds and
one by one they're all obliterated in
gory fashion screenwriter Rhett
revealed they deceptively shot footage
to use in trailers to imply the
characters larger role in the movie it
does make for a funny sequence but
laughter aside some viewers couldn't
help feeling cheated by the quick deaths
after that setup these lesser comic-book
characters have fans their demises were
a disappointment for anyone hoping to
see a crew of semi obscure Marvel heroes
in action best LGBTQ representation
Deadpool 2 is the first superhero film
to openly include LGBTQ characters in
the form of negasonic teenage warhead
yukio whose romance is a matter-of-fact
subplot throughout the film as for the
subtly pansexual Deadpool his attraction
to Colossus is amped up this time around
as well as the occasional metallic
fondle now and then
Deadpool serenades him say anything
style after the pair fall out and it's a
good thing too because Colossus comes to
Wade's aid during the battle against
juggernaut worst no true super villain
while the formation of the new super
group takes center stage in Deadpool 2
the movie lacks a true big bad guy the
sadistic headmaster of Essex House is as
close as we get to outright villainy but
it's possible that a certain genetically
altered someone has been lurking in the
shadows mr. sinister the super villain
made his first full appearance in the
uncanny x-men in 1987 the alter-ego of
Nathaniel Essex he shares a name with
Essex House the orphanage Russell
escapes from perhaps a tantalizing hint
of Sinister's involvement
he's been teased since a post-credits
sequence of x-men apocalypse but it's a
little frustrating that he hasn't
appeared yet best mid-credits scenes it
wouldn't be a Marvel movie if you didn't
stay glued to your seat during the
closing credits eagerly awaiting an
extra scene this time weighed out does
his riff on Ferris Bueller's Day Off
with not one but three mid credit scenes
by the film's conclusion cables
time-travel device is used up and he's
stuck in the present after using his
final charge to save Wade's life after
the credits roll negasonic teenage
warhead and Yukio fixed the device and
naturally Wade quickly uses it to recap
first he travels back to save Vanessa
easy choice
Deadpool's next stop is to go back in
time again and save x-force member Peter
but he's just getting started he then
makes his way into 2009 x-men origins
wolf
Green where he makes quick work of his
first onscreen incarnation shooting the
much-maligned malice Deadpool repeatedly
then he visits Ryan Reynolds and shoots
him immediately after he reads the Green
Lantern script as Deadpool Ryan Reynolds
used the opportunity to not only poke
fun of himself but to capture the kind
of what-ifs fans love to hypothesize
about should not be on your show Ryan
Reynolds worst missed opportunities not
only did the movie lack a clear villain
but that vacancy could have been filled
by at least one character who had screen
time black Tom Cassidy he amounts to
nothing more than a briefly seen brute
but in the comics black Tom has the
ability to channel energy into
destructive forceful blasts and a
grander version of the character was
originally scripted as Deadpool 2's main
villain however as Rhett Reese told CB r
they reduced his role saying his powers
are to move organic material around the
entire orphanage and the trees
everything was flying around and the
hailstorms of wood it was really cool
but it was also really really expensive
but we don't have that kind of money
however there's still hope Reese
confirmed that black Tom could return
from beyond the grave at a later date
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]